wherever you turn in this building
there are people playing of course
there's the usual pool tables and ping
pong tables but there are also go boards
chess boards vintage video game cabinets
and more recent strategy games like
Settlers of Catan because here you see
games are good I'm Hanna Frey I'm a
mathematician who specializes in
studying patterns in human behavior and
I'm also an author a broadcaster and
like rather a lot of us someone who is
fascinated by the potential for
artificial intelligence and the places
it can take us over the last 12 months
I've been working with deep mind the
london-based lab that has been called
the Apollo project of artificial
intelligence ready to go welcome to the
deep mind podcast open another door and
what do you know there's a chess
grandmaster pondering his latest move in
his early 20s Matthew Sadler was one of
Britain's all-time greatest chess
players he was there at the heart of it
all as a professional player when AI
started moving in on human chess
champions and if you know anything about
chess at all you'll remember this a
computer called deep blue has made chess
history by defeating the world's
champion Garry Kasparov this is the
moment in 1997 when
was defeated by machine it was the final
game of six and his opponent one of the
most powerful supercomputers in the
world seemed to have the upper hand the
game of chess supposedly a true test of
human intellect will never be the same
again the reigning chess champion Garry
Kasparov beaten in a devastating fashion
by a chess-playing computer built by IBM
known as deep blue one of those watching
was Matthew Sadler the big thing about
deep blue was that it wasn't actually
stronger than Kasparov won it won so
that was very annoying because everyone
you know was saying oh a computer's
beaten Kasparov you want to say yes but
it wasn't better you know Kasparov
didn't get self a bit psyched out and
you know deep blue paid well and and all
of that and then at some stage computers
came along that were a lot stronger and
then you could start using them and they
started showing you stuff that they
hadn't seen before you know incredibly
complicated tactical sequences where
you'd say that never works and yet it
does and then at that moment you sort of
give it up you sort of say okay they're
better than me and you start
appreciating what they bring to the game
and so is the story of deep blues
victory over Kasparov faded into AI
folklore people started to wonder what
game would be the next frontier for AI
research the most ambitious had their
eye on the ancient board game girl this
is not a game that responds to brute
force calculation
it requires intuition and an instinctive
appreciation of positions and beauty
unlike chess where by 2016 even a mobile
phone could play a credible game against
a grandmaster there was nothing that
came close to playing at the top level
of go but that didn't put off one man
from the challenge David Silva lead
researcher at deep mind I've always been
an ambitious person so I think at the
beginning of my PhD I set out on this
with this goal for myself to be able to
beat the world's strongest players
during my PhD which turned out to be a
little bit ambitious everyone was trying
to dissuade me from this course the head
of department took me aside and said
look you know you're just wasting your
time working on this project it's too
hard
no one will be able to do this he's seen
too many people banging the heads
against this problem and fail and he he
didn't want to see someone else in his
mind you know just bang their heads
against a problem that was too hard he
wanted you to be employable that's right
yes that's right go is an ancient
Chinese board game and although it's not
played much in the West it's arguably
the most popular board game in the world
it's considered one of the four ancient
scholarly skills of China and is taught
in school alongside sports or maths is
played on the pale wooden board engraved
with an elegant grid of 19 by 19 squares
the objective is very simple both
players are aiming to capture territory
on the board by enclosing it with their
pieces black or white known as stones
but the game itself is mind-bogglingly
sophisticated much much more than chess
even so David Silva was single-minded in
his belief that AI could master the game
go it was simply a question of how the
right approach it always seemed to me
was to allow machines to learn for
themselves this kind of intuition to
learn from themselves to be able to look
at a position and establish whether
black or white is ahead and this meant
machine learning in particular a method
with in machine learning called
reinforcement learning which is supposed
to be how humans and animals learn for
themselves through trial and error
experience but reinforcement learning on
its own wouldn't be enough it was only
when David began to work with the team
at deep mind that he spotted the missing
piece of the puzzle we'd seen a huge
revolution with something called deep
learning this is the ability for
machines to build up very rich deep
layered representations of knowledge for
themselves and that breakthrough seemed
to me to be the missing element that if
we could combine that process of being
able to build these very rich
representations of knowledge with the
kind of work which I'd been doing before
and reinforcement learning the ability
for machines to learn for themselves by
trial and error
if we put those two pieces together and
seem to me that that this was a recipe
that might have the legs to take us all
the way and by all the way David means
building an AI good enough to challenge
the very best go players in the world
this is a huge moment for both the world
of artificial intelligence and I think
the world of dope so far alphago has
beaten every challenge we've given it
but we won't know its true strength
until we play somebody who is at the top
of the world like Lisa Don
Sol March 2016 a decade after first wing
with the idea of designing a go-getting
machine
David's moment had come deep mines
contender the AI program alphago would
battle the eighteen time world champion
Lisa doll head-to-head in a televised
match of five games as the world's press
watched on with bated breath
I think the honest truth is that when I
flew out to Seoul in 2016 I was living
this very protected life as a researcher
working on this problem behind closed
doors just thinking about the
complexities of the problem and how to
how to make the system work and it was
only when I stepped off the plane and
walked into this hotel room most
absolutely jam-packed with reporters and
everything going on that suddenly the
penny dropped that this was a really big
deal that that actually you know the
consequences of this were far greater
reaching than had ever imagined there
were something like a hundred million
people watching the match as it
proceeded or something like 30,000
articles written about the match when
you arrived in Korea did you believe
that your your algorithm would win when
we arrived in Korea we actually got the
team together and I asked the team to
hold out a hand
we were playing five games and asked
everyone to hold up a hand to say how
many games after five we thought we
would win and you know many people make
many different predictions I actually
predicted for one David's prediction of
four one two alphago was a clear
expression of confidence but once the
match started the doubt started creeping
in I feel I made the mistake of under
estimating the quality of a real human
world champion when we were actually
playing the match I realized just how
immensely versatile Lisa doll was as a
player in his ability to push alphago to
his limits not just in one game but then
coming along again the next game and
trying a very different strategy and
in the next game trying a different
strategy like pushing them probing for
weaknesses all the way through and we
were pushing alphago in two regimes that
we'd never tested actually I don't know
if you've ever watched a televised game
of go but as a single stone is placed
calmly onto the board the commentators
and the audience watching on react with
the same ferocity of emotion and
excitement as they would a football game
even so there was one moment during the
first game where the response from the
crowd really stood out a moment where
even Lisa dolls expression fixed into a
look of shock his mouth fell open and
his hand came up to his face everyone's
expectation had been that Lisa doll
would eventually emerged triumphant it
was just a matter of time until alphago
made a mistake the game apparently to
the human commentators were still
balanced and at that point in time
alphago made an extremely bold move
quite nice to be here at David his
backstage with demis hassabis one of the
founders of deep mind watching alphago's
every move and their reaction is caught
on the camera in that is not a confident
face in Gautam's it invaded in something
which appeared to be least adult's
territory and alphago jumped right
inside to the region which seemed like
it belonged to Lisa doll and said okay
you know come and get me and it was an
audacious move and you could judge by
Lisa doles reaction that he he wasn't
expecting it he was expecting perhaps
more timid more computer-like response
and the reality was that alphago was
using its intuition to judge that if it
jumped in here it couldn't compute all
the way to the end all of these possible
outcomes but it had a sense that this
would work out well for it the first
round was a convincing victory for
alphago
roll on day 2 round 2 and alphago had
another surprise up its sleeve in the
second game the human commentators were
Ashley I mean the only way I can think
of his gobsmacked in their reaction
that's a very that's a very surprising
move this was the now-famous move 37
alphago had placed a stone on the fifth
line a move that no human player would
even consider there's these deeply
built-in beliefs about the game and one
of them is that in the game of Go you
can think of all these different lines
upon which stones could be played the
first line is closest to the edge the
second line the third line the fourth
line and there's a rule in the game of
Go which is that when you approach one
of these stones with diagonally it's
called a shoulder head that you never
ever do your shoulder head above the
fourth line and this has just been so
ingrained in Ingo knowledge because most
of the time it's true like most of the
time this is a very useful common-sense
piece of knowledge which helps go
players to exclude a vast range of very
bad moves but in this particular
position what alphago realized was that
playing on the fifth line and playing
the shoulder hit on the fifth line
actually just worked beautifully in the
context of this position with all of its
other stones in such a way that the
outcome was really favorable because in
the end of that game that stone ended up
being instrumental right it kind of
joined up to everything that's right
yeah that stone became so influential in
the game and it just worked forming this
big net that surrounded a vast swathe of
territory in the center
alphago just wasn't playing in a
mechanical way it was breaking the norms
and conventions of this ancient game it
was creating something a pattern of
playing that went way beyond the
approaches that humans had ever
considered and it was doing so
successfully move 37 would eventually
seal victory for the machine looking
back on the match Lisa Dahl spoke about
how this very move shifted his entire
view of the map
I thought alphago was based on
probability calculation and it was
merely a machine but when I saw this
move I changed my mind
shirley alphago was creative this move
was really creative and beautiful do you
think that was the AI illustrating real
creativity I think we need to challenge
ourselves to ask you know what is
creativity I think creativity should be
defined as anything which takes us out
of our expected patterns of behavior and
I think in in that sense it truly was
creative
alphago won the first three games but
the match wasn't over for Lisa doll just
yet in the fourth game he managed to
come back fighting against his opponent
Lisa doll was a true gentleman and we
couldn't have chosen anyone better to
represent humankind for this match he
not only strove his utmost to the very
end to play and devised all kinds of
amazing counter strategies to - alphago
but he dealt with the immense pressure
of having all of these people watch him
in really a profoundly human way he he
found it very hard he was humble
I think it hurt his pride to lose to the
computer but he came back and he found
new strength in that and was able to
ultimately emerge with immense pride at
having beaten alphago in one game and
been part of this pivotal moment for AI
at the end of the six days the final
score was alphago for
doll 1 so alphago became the first
computer champion at the game to go and
it was there a major result for
artificial intelligence and you won the
sweepstakes and I won the sweepstake
this is the deep mind podcast an
introduction to AI research from the
people behind
Alfred Go news of the March rippled
around the world Mac Botvinnik now deep
Minds director of neuroscience research
was one of the millions watching the
first reaction that people had in the
NGO community was oh it feels a little
sad that now there's a computer program
that can beat our hero but then it
didn't take long before people started
to realize wait a minute this is
actually really exciting we're not stuck
with our own limitations in terms of
seeing the possibilities of how to play
this game now there are new horizons
opened up to us we can find new forms of
beauty in this game I think that's sort
of in microcosm now what what I think we
can hope for from from AI more generally
and for David's this victory was always
the heart of a bigger picture it's not
really the case that I've ever had to
stop and question and say well what next
because the what next is clear we want
to take this further we want to build
machines which can achieve the same
level of performance but across all
kinds of challenging domains why stop
with go you once said the that you think
that the game of gos is the holy grail
of artificial intelligence do you still
think that as the case I think the
history of AI has been a number of
pivotal moments where for a period of
time a particular domain has been a
centerpiece of everyone's attention so
for a while the centerpiece of attention
was the game of chess when deep blue
defeated Garry Kasparov that marked the
end of an era when chess was no longer
their domain that people cared about and
and the world moved on but before the
world moved on from go David was curious
about just how far he could push the AI
really the open question for me was how
can a system learn for itself
entirely
with no human input if there was no
human supervisor there say here's the
inputs his the guidance here's the
examples of how humans play what if we
started really tabula rasa which means
start from a blank slate and the system
just has to learn everything for itself
starting from completely random play is
it able to learn for itself to play go
to the highest caliber of play that's
possible since their triumphs in 2016
David and his team have been busy
working on that new algorithm alpha zero
the original go beta alphago learned to
play by stunning millions of games
played by human experts alpha zero on
the other hand learns completely from
scratch from zero human knowledge
instead it picks up the game by playing
against itself millions of times
initially its gameplay as weak and
erratic but over time the system learns
to identify the best moves and
strategies it try something and if a
particular pattern is successful and it
ends up winning the game against itself
it uses that pattern more and if another
pattern ends up causing it to lose the
game it will play that pattern less and
over time it builds up this very rich
deep representation of knowledge one of
these so-called neural networks and it's
able to then go out and beat the world's
strongest programs which is better
alphago or alpha zero that go amazingly
we discovered that the system which had
learned completely for itself without a
single piece of human knowledge ended up
being far stronger in the long run and
defeated the original version of alphago
by hundred games to zero oh my god so
hang on you weakened it by giving it
human knowledge it turns out that we
have a tendency as human designers to
believe that we know how to make the
system stronger but quite often it turns
out that by putting our own
predispositions and preferences into our
programs we actually make them weaker
you
we're not needing any human input alpha
zero doesn't particularly care what game
is playing as long as you can give it
the rules is by no means limited to go
by now alpha0 has taught itself from
scratch how to master the Japanese game
of shogi it is currently the world's
best shogi playing machine despite there
only being one human in the deep mind
building who knows how to play and to
come full circle after only four hours
of playing itself alpha zero mastered
the game of chess to a superhuman level
[Music]
so far just a small handful of chess
greats have been able to test their
skills against the machine including
chess grandmaster Matthew Sadler who we
met earlier and Women's International
Master
Natasha Regan they've co-authored a book
about alpha zero called game changer and
outside of the research team at deep
mind they probably spent more time with
alpha zero than anyone here's Natasha I
played out four zero once and it wasn't
a very long game how many moves did you
get - oh I think it would have been less
than 20 and and I'd have to say it was
very direct
I played something sacrificial I thought
I'd try a opening thing it might not
know it and it exploited it very quickly
got its pieces out on attacking squares
straightaway and it won quite quick I
wouldn't get to 2020 mousse if I played
it take me down that's pretty yeah it
does have a very smooth human style
against me there was no need for it to
do anything complicated it just played
better moves over a long period of time
and just push me back gradually I
wouldn't have been able to guess that
was playing into the computer it would
if I had to guess a human it would've
been someone like Coulson or or Karpov
he's very smooth positional players who
just beat you by playing good moves
and that like alphago before it is a key
thing about the playing style of the AI
they're not like IBM's deep blue that
beat Garry Kasparov back in 1997 or any
of its descendants they playing with a
very mechanical style computer like
style they're very defensive they only
ever take calculated risks but alpha
zero on the other hand it conducts its
attack in quite a structured way so it
takes a count of the whole board and it
tends not to get attacked itself so it
gets to a position where its own
position is quite stable and safe and
then it can bring all its pieces in
consorted way into doing an attack it's
doing what humans do but only so much
better that's the thing it really
blending them that is it actually doing
original stuff yes it is
we've been playing chess for over 400
years so actually probably every single
move on the board has probably been
played once by someone somewhere you can
actually see my goodness some displayed
44 million games against itself it's
actually repeated our whole chess
history for itself and in that time is
just identified what the most important
things are of all that we've discovered
I mean that's what makes style alpha
zero has substance as well as style
right now in 2019 it simultaneously
holds the titles are being the best
player in the world at go shogi and
chess and it's not just being greedy the
whole point of this project was to build
an intelligent system flexible enough to
respond to a range of problems and while
alpha zero might not quite be able to
tackle cancer diagnosis or energy
efficiency there is a good reason why
deep minder playing with building these
all-purpose machines
in the world of games our goal of course
is not just to play chess or go or or
whatever our goal is to have impact on
some of the world's most challenging
problems which are facing society but in
order to do so we need to gain
understanding we need to really deeply
understand these systems for ourselves
first and games provide the perfect
testbed for doing so games are like the
ultimate mini universe you know all the
rules there's a clear winner at the end
you can look back at the end of the game
and decide what went wrong and if you
lose well it doesn't matter you can just
start another round the big problems
though the ones we eventually want to
tackle they are quite a lot more
complicated the real worlds are really
messy place and you end up with these
amazingly complex things like human
beings and how they interact with each
other and societies and companies and
all these amazing things which we've
built up in our world we need to be able
to understand them to be able to have a
hope to apply something like alphago to
to make progress in order to make
progress then we need to be able to
apply systems that can operate even when
the what rules are unknown and that is a
big remaining challenge which is not yet
being addressed by alphago or alpha zero
if you want to know more about how games
have been and continue to be used as a
testbed in AI research then head over to
the show notes where you can also
explore the world of AI research beyond
deep mind and we'd welcome your feedback
or your questions on any aspects of
artificial intelligence that we're
covering in this series so if you want
to join in the discussion or point us to
stories or resources that you think
other listeners would find helpful then
please let us know you can message us on
Twitter or you can email us podcast at
deep mind calm
[Music]